Good morning!
It is a great honor to be in Tokyo,...
...the first stop on my first visit to Asia as president of the United States.
It's good to be among so many of you Japanese. And I see a few Americans here...
...who work every day to strengthen the bonds between our two countries,...
...including my longtime friend and our new ambassador to Japan, John Roos.
It is wonderful to be back in Japan.
Some of you may be aware that when I was a young boy,...
...my mother brought me to Kamakura...
...where I looked up at that centuries-old symbol of peace and tranquility,...
...the great bronze Amida Buddha.
And as a child, I was more focused on the matcha ice cream.
And I wanna thank Prime Minister Hatoyama for sharing some of those memories...
...with more ice cream last night at dinner.
Thank you very much.
But I have never forgotten the warmth and the hospitality...
...that the Japanese people showed a young American far from home,...
...and I feel that same spirit on this visit.
In the gracious welcome of Prime Minister Hatoyama.
In the extraordinary honor of the meeting with their Imperial Majesties, the Emperor and Empress...
...on the 20th anniversary of his ascension to the Chrysanthemum Throne.
In the hospitality shown by the Japanese people.
And of course, I could not come here...
...without sending my greetings and gratitude to the citizens of Obama, Japan.